die kommandos spezialkräfte eine top
elite militär spezialeinheit ausgebildet
für so hatte sachen dass dieses video
dem monetarisiert wird wenn ich nur
daran denken würde sie auszusprechen
bestehen aus den härtesten und mutigsten
des ganzen landes welche für die
extremsten einsätze bis an die zähne mit
muskeln wissen und taktik bewaffnet sind
durch einen knallharten fitness test
wird jeder anflug von schwäche und
durchschnittlichkeit in den eigenen
reihen im keim erstickt oder mit anderen
worten kennen oder recht geschoben für
jemanden wie mich
[Musik]
sollte ich noch ein bisschen trainieren
ich werde den test zuerst kommt selbst
ohne training versuchen schauen wie ich
abschneide dann eine woche hart
trainieren und mich am ende den test
erneut stellen um herauszufinden wie
sich nicht verbessere und ob ich den
test bestehen dieses video wird
unterstützt von skill scheer
und so sieht der fitnesstest aus bei
klimmzügen muss man mindestens fünf
erreichen beim 49 meter pendelt auf gibt
es eine punkteskala unter 10,3 sekunden
gibt es den ersten punkt und man hat
bestanden sechs punkte gibt es ab 8,5
sekunden weiter geht's mit mindestens 21
17 40 sekunden beim standweitsprung muss
man die 195 zentimeter schlagen und bei
liegestützen müssen in 40 sekunden
mindestens 13 drin sein innerhalb von
zwölf minuten muss man mindestens 1750
meter beim dauerlauf absolvieren den
sieben kilometer marsch inklusive 20
kilogramm gepäck unter 52 minuten und
für 500 meter schwimmen darf man maximal
15 minuten brauchen wir beginnen mit der
ersten unvorbereiteten durchführung des
eignungstests erste disziplin gerade
klimmzüge erwartung 55 km züge sollten
kein problem sein
für nach bestandenen standen zweite
disziplin pendelt auf vier mal neun
meter erwartung unter 10 3 sekunden
erreicht 9 81 sekunden bestanden aber
nur mit zwei von sechs punkten sechs
punkte gebe es unter 8,6 sekunden dritte
disziplin sit ups in 40 sekunden
erwartung mindestens 21 erreicht 17
durchgefallen vierte disziplin
standweitsprung erwartung mindestens 195
erreicht zwei meter 16 bestanden zwei
von sechs punkten fünfte disziplin
liegestütze mitklatschen in 40 sekunden
er wartet mindestens 13
[Musik]
erreicht 16
wir standen zwei von sechs punkten
sechster disziplin zwölf minuten
dauerlauf erwartet mindestens 1750 meter
[Musik]
erreicht 1700 meter durchgefallen siebte
disziplin 1 7 kilometer marsch mit 20
kilogramm zusatzgewicht in unter 52
minuten
ich kriege ich hier so erreicht wurden
18 15 minuten durchgefallen achte
disziplin 500 meter schwimmen in 15
minuten abgebrochen
aufgrund von unterkühlung gefahr müssen
wir das für unseren test leider
ausschließen
mir tut alles weh gestern war ich nach
dem ersten fitnesstest schon genug
deswegen geht es heute weiter mit dem
ersten trainingstag
ich weiß dass ich innerhalb von einer
woche keine muskelberge anhäufen kann
aber um den bestmöglichen
trainingseffekt zu erzielen werde ich
nach einem sehr einfachen 21 blitz
trainieren das heißt ich trainiere
täglich und wechselt zwischen zwei
trainings glücken ab wenn man so will
damit die muskeln wenigstens
einigermaßen zeit haben sich zu
regenerieren besteht block 1 aufrücken
und beinmuskulatur und block 2 aus brust
bauch und ausdauer
ich trainiere die muskelgruppen die ich
für den ksk finden ist es brauche in
leicht abgewandelter form damit ich erst
am ende des experimente sehe wie mein
fortschritt in den eigentlichen
disziplin wirklich ist heute ist
dienstag also trainiere ich für die
klimmzüge und aber auch für die kraft in
den beinen nicht für den pendelt auf für
den zehn kilometer marsch und aber auch
für den weitsprung brauche das mache ich
mit block 1 und wer besteht aus vier
sätze glatt zug und zwar jeweils acht
wiederholungen explosive sprungkraft
übungen und kniebeugen studiert schon
alles
jede woche versuche ich ein cooles
experiment zu machen indem ich etwas
neues lernen da ich es liebe mir selbst
sachen beizubringen weißkirchen findet
ihr tausende klassen zu allen interessen
wie zb fotografie produktivität
selbständigkeit und viele mehr und das
für anfänger bis hin zu profis wie zum
beispiel hat die klasse hielt
reaktivität autobild havelse wird last
von thomas frank echt geholfen meine
abläufe und strukturen zu optimieren in
der klasse zieht er von a bis z eine
richtig heftige blaupause auf mit der
wir alle unsere ziele schnell erreichen
können die ersten 500 meiner abonnenten
die auf den link in der beschreibung
klicken bekommen zwei probe monate der
premium mitgliedschaft kostenlos so dass
ihr eure kreativität erkunden könnt
skills er hat keine nervige werbung
bringt immer neue klassen heraus und
kostet mit einem jährlichen abo nur acht
euro im monat also schlag zu am mittwoch
wird für die ausbau bei allen
laufdisziplinen trainiert in dem ich im
gelände joggen gehe anschließend brust
maschine und normale liegestütze welche
mich auf die liegestützen mitklatschen
vorbereiten sollen
normale liegestützen tatsächlich viel
mehr als diese mit klatschen sie sehen
zwar viel lustiger aus aber da sind auch
echt viel anstrengender am donnerstag
wiederholt sich der ganze spaß mit block
1 bestehend aus lastzug sprungkraft und
kniebeugen nur das ist diesmal
tausendmal schmerzhafter ist da ich in
jedem einzelnen muskel meines körpers
muskelkater habe und man konnte es ist
ja ich muss echt ein bisschen langsamer
machen sonst krieg hinein fast gar
nichts mehr weil man einfach alles viel
zu sehr weh tut und haben nicht einfach
am ende noch schlechter als am anfang
um möglichst viel zu trainieren aber bis
zum finalen test trotzdem genug pause zu
haben
trainiere ich zwei tage vorher schon
sieben uhr morgens der ganze samstag ist
eine kugel tag den ich sichtlich
genießen und sonntag 16 uhr ist es
soweit 54 stunden nach meiner letzten
trainingseinheit steht der finale kreis
karte ist endlich an
also ich hab noch mal mega gut gegessen
damit aber richtig energie habe aber
ehrlich gesagt hat trotzdem noch überall
muss nicht halt naja heftig
erste disziplin klimmzüge erwartet
mindestens fünf erreicht a8 bestanden
verbessert und 3 also 37 prozent mehr
als vorher zweite disziplin pendelt auf
erwartet unter 10 3 sekunden erreicht
868 bestanden verbessert um 1,16
sekunden also zwölf prozent schneller
als vorher dritte disziplin sit ups in
40 sekunden erwartet mindestens 21
erreicht 27 bestanden verbessert um 10
also 59 prozent mehr vierte disziplin
standweitsprung erwartet mindestens 195
cm erreicht er war knapp 223 zentimeter
bestanden verbessert um sieben
zentimeter
also 3 prozent weiterer als zuvor das
ist doch was fünfte disziplin
liegestütze in 40 sekunden er wartet 13
erreicht rufen war das 18 bestanden
verbessert um 2 also 13 prozent mehr
ok jetzt die disziplin bei der letzten
mal knapp verloren haben nur 50 meter
das nämlich nicht sicher dass ich das
jetzt auch wenn wir alles mit draufgeht
statt disziplin 6 12 minuten dauerlauf
erwartet mindestens 1750 meter
erreicht 219 kilometer das ist ein
ordentliches stück verbessert um 490
meter als 29 prozent weiter auch mehr
gas gegeben aber ich denke dass jetzt
gleich kommt es umso schwieriger
okay ich habe jetzt ein bisschen erholt
mir geht es mir besser meine füße tun
weh
jetzt wird marschiert mit einem schweren
rucksack wie beim letzten mal auch werde
ich mal einfach ein bisschen mehr gas
geben und mich dann erholen disziplin 77
kilometer marsch erwartet in unter 52
minuten erreicht 51 nur 46 sekunden
ich hab's geschafft war das klar aber
ich habe auch ehrlich gesagt genauso
viel power gegeben
das ist gerade so geschafft habe weil
wir einfach alle institute verbessert um
6 minuten und 17 sekunden also zwölf
prozent schneller
ich hab's geschafft krass ich hab's nach
einer woche geschafft gerade bei den
ausdauer sachen wie zum beispiel joggen
und diesem sieben kilometer marsch war
es einfach übertrieben heftig gerade da
hab ich nach den ersten ein zwei mal
joggen schon richtig gemerkt mich
einfach nicht mehr so viel seitenstechen
kriege und einfach ein bisschen mehr
luft haben und nicht einfach länger
schneller laufen kann und nicht immer
direkten dieses ganz langsam mit joggen
zurückfallen muss weil ich sonst einfach
sterbe aber auch bei diesen muskel
sachen habe ich mich überall zumindest
ein stück weit verbessert ich denke aber
auch dass wenn ich jetzt so bleiben
würde wie ich aktuell bin wo ich gerade
so den test besteht also ich nicht
wirklich haben beim peace cup bleiben
würde
ich bin jetzt in der woche natürlich
nicht megatrucks muskulös geworden aber
meine muskeln die sind auf ihnen so viel
einsatz bereit
heute sind vielmehr auf abruf bereits
dich dadurch dass ich jetzt einfach mehr
sport gemacht habe mehr da wenn ich sie
brauche auch wenn ich den test bestanden
habe zum beispiel mit 27 46 sekunden für
die volle punktzahl bräuchte man 40 und
echt keine ahnung wer das schafft also
das ist ja einfach ein setup pro sekunde
und ich habe wirklich schon so gas geben
ließen ging und selbst wenn ich noch
mehr kraft gehabt hätte ich hätte
einfach gar nicht so schnell geschafft
aber sascha huber hat zum beispiel
geschafft von dem habe ich auch die idee
zu diesem video zeigt gerne mal ab wie
er den test komplett rasiert ich mache
sowieso ja schon jede woche eines dieser
elemente aber ab sofort wieder öfter mal
im video kommen über das was sich
innerhalb von 30 tagen oder auch mal 90
tagen schaffen wenn ihr das nicht
verpassen möchte abonniert gerne diesen
kanal und dann sehen wir zum nächsten
halt macht es gut
[Musik]